during the covid lockdown this headline
went viral
nearly half of men say they do most of
the homeschooling
three percent of women agree i bring
this
up not to debate who's right but because
it's a great example of something called
egocentric bias most people think they
do
most of the work for example researchers
have asked authors of
multi-author papers what percentage of
the work they personally did
and when they add up those percentages
the sum is on average 140 percent
when couples are asked to estimate how
much of the housework they do the
combined total is almost always
over a hundred percent now you might
think this is because people want to
appear
more helpful than they actually are but
that's not it
when couples are asked what fraction of
the fights they start or how much of the
mess is theirs
the total is again over a hundred people
think they do more of the work
but they also think they cause more of
the problems so why is this
i think it's simply because you
experience and remember vividly all of
what you do
but not all of what everyone else does
so naturally you overestimate your own
contributions and
underestimate others and i think this
bias
leads us to underestimate the influence
of other things on our lives like
the role luck plays in our success take
hockey players for example
if you ask a professional hockey player
how they managed to reach the nhl
they might mention their hard work
determination great coaches their
parents willingness to get up at 5am and
so on
but they probably won't acknowledge how
lucky they were to be born
in january and yet in many years 40
of hockey players selected into top tier
leagues are born in the first quarter of
the year
compared to just 10 percent in the
fourth quarter an
early birthday can make you up to four
times as likely to be a pro hockey
player
and the reason for this disparity is
presumably because the cutoff date for
kids hockey leagues is january 1st
those born in the first part of the year
are a little older and so on average
bigger and faster than kids in their
league born
late in the year now as they grow up
this difference should eventually shrink
to nothing
but it doesn't because the young kids
who share the most promise are given
more time on the ice and enter more
tournaments where they receive better
coaching and improve their skills
and these advantages compound year after
year so by the time you get to the pros
birthdays are heavily skewed towards the
start of the year
but does any professional hockey player
feel thankful for their birthday
probably not and we are all like that
largely oblivious to the fortunate
events that support our success
probably the most significant bit of
luck many of us enjoy is being born into
a prosperous country
around half the variance in income
received by people around the world is
explained by their country of residence
and that country's income distribution
if you were born in burundi for example
which has the world's
lowest gross national income per capita
of just 730
a year it doesn't matter how smart or
hard-working you are
you're unlikely to earn much as an adult
now many people get offended if you
point out how big a role chance plays in
their success
and i get it if we are just a product of
our circumstances
then our hard work and our talent seem
to count for nothing
people think it has to be either skill
or luck
that explains success but the truth is
you need both
take these eight track and field world
records all the athletes who achieve
these records are obviously
world class extremely dedicated and
talented and yet
when they achieved their world records
seven out of eight had a tailwind
now these athletes all had the ability
to win a gold medal but to set the world
record
required a bit of luck as well the
importance of luck increases the greater
the number of applicants
applying for just a few spaces consider
the most recent class of nasa astronauts
from over 18 300 applicants in 2017
only 11 were selected and went on to
graduate from the astronaut training
program
now we can make a toy model of the
selection process
let's assume that astronauts are
selected mostly based on skill
experience and hard work but also say
five percent
as a result of luck fortunate
circumstances
for each applicant i randomly generated
a skill score out of a hundred
and i also randomly generated a luck
score out of a hundred
then i added those numbers together
weighted in the 95
to 5 ratio to get an overall score
this score represents the selector's
judgments meaning the top 11 by this
metric
would become astronauts and i repeated
this simulation a thousand times
representing
a thousand different astronaut
selections and what i found was
the astronauts who were picked were very
lucky
they had an average luck score of 94.7
so how many of the selected astronauts
would have been in the top 11 based on
skill
alone the answer was on average only 1.6
that means even with luck accounting for
just 5
of the outcome 9 or maybe 10 of the 11
applicants selected
would have been different if luck played
no role at all
when competition is fierce being
talented and hardworking is important
but it's not enough to guarantee success
you also need to catch a break
largely i think we're unaware of our
good luck because by definition it's not
something we did
like the housework done by your
significant other it goes unappreciated
and here's the crazy thing downplaying
the importance of chance events may
actually
improve your probability of success
because
if you perceive an outcome to be
uncertain you're less likely to invest
effort in it which further decreases
your chances of success
so it's a useful delusion to believe you
are in full control of your destiny
i mean if i had known how bad i was when
i started youtube or how much work it
would take
i might have given up right then welcome
to veritasium
an online science video blog now there
may be another benefit to overlooking
your lucky breaks which is
it makes it easier to justify your place
in society
if you have a lot of wealth or power you
can just chalk it up to your own
intelligence effort and perseverance it
makes it easier to accept inequality
in one experiment participants were put
in groups of three in small rooms to
discuss a complex moral problem and one
person in each group was randomly
designated the team leader
half an hour later the experimenter came
by with four cookies for each team
so who got the extra cookie in each case
it went to the team leader
even though they had no special aptitude
they didn't have extra responsibilities
and they'd gotten their position through
chance alone
once you have achieved a certain status
it seems natural to feel like you
deserve it and
all the other good things that come your
way now this is just an anecdote but
whenever i've been upgraded to fly a
business class
i've always observed the worst behavior
in my fellow privileged passengers they
just act so entitled and uncourteous and
research has found evidence for this as
well in another experiment participants
were asked to think of a good thing that
happened to them recently
and then one group was asked to list
their own personal qualities or actions
that made that good thing happen
another group was asked to list external
factors beyond their control
that led to the event and a control
group was simply asked to list reasons
why the good thing happened
now for completing this task
participants were told they would be
paid a dollar
but at the end they were offered the
option to donate some or
all of the money to a charity results
showed those who listed their own
personal attributes contributed
25 less than those who listed external
factors beyond their control
now think of what all this means for
people in our society specifically for
people in positions of power like
business leaders and politicians now
undoubtedly most of them
are talented and hardworking but they
have also been luckier than most
and like most of us they don't realize
just how lucky they are
and this gives them a distorted view of
reality they're kind of
living in a form of survivor bias all
these leaders have worked hard and
ultimately succeeded so
to them the world appears fair in their
experience it rewards hard work
but what they don't have is the
experience of all the people who have
worked hard
and failed so what are they to make of
people less successful than themselves
well the natural conclusion is that
they must just be less talented or less
hard-working
and this perspective makes them less
inclined to be generous to give back
and they are the ones who set the rules
for how society operates
and this is particularly unfortunate
since one of the main ways many of us
are lucky
is in our country of residence but what
is a country
except for the things put there by
people who came before the
roads and the schools public transport
emergency services clean air and water
everything like that it seems a cruel
trick of our psychology that
successful people without any malice
will credit their success largely to
their
own hard work and ingenuity and
therefore contribute less to maintaining
the very
circumstances that made that success
possible in the first place
the good news is that acknowledging our
fortunate circumstances
not only brings us more in line with
reality it also makes us more likeable
in a study where people had to read the
transcript of a fictional 60 minutes
interview with a biotech entrepreneur
experimenters tried changing just the
last paragraph where the interviewee
is talking about the reasons for their
company's success in one version the
entrepreneur
personally takes credit for the success
they've had but in the other
he says luck played a significant role
now people who read the luck version of
the transcript
judged the entrepreneur as kinder and
thought they'd be more likely to be
close friends with him than those who
read the other version of the transcript
and raising our awareness of fortunate
events can also make us happier
because it allows us to feel gratitude
personally i am grateful to michael
stevens of vsauce who on october 7th
2012
posted the video how much does a shadow
weigh which shouts out my slow-motion
slinky drop video
and within three days my subscribers had
increased by a third and within a month
they had doubled leading me to quit my
part-time job and work exclusively on
youtube videos
and i'm grateful to the writer of the
free newspaper they give out on the
trains in sydney who didn't quite
understand electricity
leading me to post this picture of their
article to my instagram with the caption
what's wrong with this picture and i'm
lucky that the first person to answer
correctly
was a beautiful woman who became my
future wife
yep that is how i met your mother
now initially i wanted to make this
video just to say our circumstances and
psychology conspire to make us oblivious
to our own luck
this leads successful people to view the
world as fair and those less successful
than them as less talented or
less hardworking and this is before you
factor in any discrimination or
prejudice
but it also became apparent to me that i
should talk about what to do if you want
to be successful in such a world and i
think the best advice
is paradoxical first you must believe
that you are in complete control of your
destiny
and that your success comes down only to
your own talent and hard work
but second you've got to know that's not
true
for you or anyone else so you have to
remember if you do
achieve success that luck played a
significant role and given your good
fortune
you should do what you can to increase
the luck of others
hey so i had an idea for what i could do
to increase the luck of others
and that is to give away a hundred
snatims kits to people who couldn't
otherwise afford them
so if you didn't know snatums is a
product that i invented and kickstarted
five years
ago it's a molecular modeling kit where
all the atoms snap together magnetically
now i made it because i really wanted to
tackle the misconception that bonds
store energy they don't it takes energy
to
break them and you can feel that with
snatums recently i completely
retooled snatums so there are small
holes where the magnets are
this allows them to touch directly
increasing the bonding strength so you
can form bigger
more stable molecules i call these
snatums
x and yes they are backwards compatible
with original snatums
so here's my idea for the next month you
can buy snatums for 10
off using the code give luck and for
each one sold i will give a kit to
someone who can't afford one
up to a limit of a hundred so i'll put
links and more details in the
description
and i really want to thank you for
watching and thank you for
all my good luck